The car's instance methods look pretty good. Now you're going to implement the
addFriend method for the person class. We decided earlier that the person class
will need instance variables for name and friends. Now the code for add friend
will go here. Before you can go this, I need to tell you a couple things about
strings and instance variables. You can add strings. If I make a string,
addedStrings, which is TJ plus Jamesha, addedStrings now contains TJJamesha.
You can add together as many strings as you want. Now to talk about instance
variables. A person object can read the name of another person object,
friend.name will give you the name of the new friend. There's one more thing. I
told you earlier that we should store the names in a string separated by
spaces. So I don't want it to look like TJ Jamesha all crammed together I want
a space in between each name and the name following it. Now its your turn to
implement the addFriend method.